If what you're saying now,
especially with Hulu,
but,
uh,
you know,
before that with youtube and with,
um,
you know,
network sites like nbc.com and so forth,
um,
is,
uh,
you know,
the availability of,
of,
of online video,
you know,
uh,
with uh,
you know,
more and more ubiquitous broadband
connections.
Um,
you know,
video becomes something that's,
uh,
you know,
easy to get online and,
and very compelling.
You know,
the idea that you can watch anything you
want whenever you want it is,
uh,
you know,
that has a lot of appeal for obvious
reasons.
Um,
and um,
television obviously isn't set up that
way.
Uh,
you know,
and frankly,
the cable companies,
uh,
you know,
which have enormous amounts of
bandwidth,
uh,
you know,
coming into the home,
um,
uh,
you know,
most of that bandwidth is now taken up
with analog programming,
um,
which,
you know,
it doesn't have nearly the efficiency of
digital,
but with it,
you know,
change over to,
to digital,
um,
you know,
that's,
that's going to be going away soon.
Um,
and,
um,
uh,
you know,
people are,
what's happening I think is that people
are beginning to,
to confront the fact that,
you know,
when you watch tv it becomes really hard
to find what you want.
Um,
you know,
there,
there might be sure on demand
programming,
but you know,
even to find the right on demand channel
is not exactly easy.
Um,
you know,
plus,
there's a very limited availability for,
for what you want.
Um,
and you know,
by contrast you can go online and,
um,
uh,
you know,
easily search for it.
And if it's there,
you can,
uh,
you know,
you can watch it.
And if it's not there on a,
you know,
a legit site,
you can find it on a pirate site,
you know,
uh,
in more and more often.
And it's now,
you know,
it's still a relatively small number of
people who,
uh,
you know,
have the sort of tech savvy and the
desire to,
to,
you know,
go that route,
but it's not going to be the case for
very long.
Um,
and,
um,
so we're really only one step away from,
uh,
you know,
watching shows on the Internet,
on your computer to watching them on TV
and companies like box the are,
are,
you know,
starting to make that possible,
uh,
you know,
starting to make that a plausible
option.
Um,
and when that happens,
uh,
you know,
the whole,
idea of television as we know it is
going to,
you know,
it's going to change.
Um,
uh,
you know,
people are,
um,
do you think people are paying,
uh,
you know,
kind of enormous sums,
uh,
on a monthly basis for,
you know,
packages of programming.
Much of us,
they don't really even want.
And,
um,
uh,
you know,
to,
uh,
to be able to,
you know,
instead,
um,
get anything you do want on a completely
on demand basis and watch it on your,
on your tv set and it's going to be a
very,
very compelling proposition.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
the problem for the networks and for the
cable companies is that that's not the
way the business is structured so far.
You know,
the business is structured,
uh,
you know,
around cable companies,
pain,
uh,
you know,
television networks,
uh,
you know,
cable networks that is,
um,
you know,
large sums per user,
um,
and for,
for the right to carry their
programming.
And then,
uh,
you know,
making money by charging the users for,
for,
for the right to see that programming.
Um,
you know,
when you have free online video that you
can watch on your tv set that,
you know,
it kind of does an end run around that
whole set up.
And which is to say,
you know,
it really calls into question the entire
economic basis of,
of television that we have right.